es la hambruna de la crisis climática en
el sur de madagascar dos de cada cinco
personas necesitan ayuda alimentaria de
emergencia debido a las sequías que por
cuarto año consecutivo han devastado los
cultivos principal medio de subsistencia
de los locales
matricular al por la mañana sólo tomamos
agua con azúcar para el almuerzo se
tritura maíz seco y por la noche a veces
no tenemos nada a menos que haya un
pequeño ingreso en el día entonces
podemos comprar arroz observar el
calentamiento global cambio los patrones
climáticos de la región sin lluvia los
campos están desnudos y muchos pasan
días sin comer
desde hace casi tres años las cosas han
cambiado no hay más lluvia no hay más
campos debido a la sequía puedo pasar
días sin comer y la voluntad según los
expertos las temperaturas en el sur de
áfrica están aumentando el doble
respecto a la tasa mundial provocando
una nueva crisis de refugiados y
desplazados climáticos personas que no
huyen de los conflictos sino de las
hambrunas provocadas por la emergencia
climática según unicef se espera que
medio millón de niños sufra desnutrición
aguda en madagascar
baja pocos otros
contaminamos menos en comparación con
otros países del mundo
monge matic hoy no está parte de
madagascar es víctima del cambio
climático excepto que no han participado
en él y lo que esperamos hoy de las
superpotencias es que los países que más
contaminan deben ayudar a los países que
menos contaminan para que podamos
mitigar el impacto
enfocamos
a los países del sur global llevan años
exigiendo mayores responsabilidades a
las naciones ricas que como parte del
acuerdo climático de parís de 2015
acordaron reservar 100.000 millones al
año en ayudas a los países empobrecidos
una promesa hasta ahora incumplida